It's been a while things have changed I
started hearing whispers about thrawn's
return as heir to the Empire we
have to prepare for the worst
the Jedi fell a long time
ago there aren't many left
Perhaps it's time to begin again
Ahsoka, Original Series streaming August 23rd
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie they released
a brand new Ahsoka trailer to announce the release
date with some new footage so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel I will
be doing videos for all the episodes just like
the Mandalorian series it's a spin-off of the
Mandalorian so be sure to subscribe to get
everything this part of the timeline is what we
call the Mando versus basically there are a couple
spin-offs that are happening like the Skeleton
Crew series is another mandover spin-off but I
don't think that we'll see that till like early
next year originally it was going to come this
year but they've kind of delayed everything just
a little bit there'll be eight episodes of Ahsoka
Dave filoni confirmed that they're basically
picking up where things left off at the end
of Star Wars Rebels and will probably see some
of those Star Wars Rebels ending scenes in live
action like some of these scenes replay what
we saw at the very end of rebels with the big
time jump but he said it'll basically start with
Ahsoka Sabine Wren and Hera wandering through the
Galaxy in Ahsoka still being kind of a loner
in Outsider even amongst the new Republic as
it's risen even though she was a huge part in
helping the Rebellion form and overthrow the
Empire during the events of the original trilogy
that's mostly because she stayed wary of any
organization whether they say that they're good
or bad Empire New Republic anybody that wields a
lot of power they kind of got into that during
the Mandalorian season 3 where they wanted to
make the new Republic seem like it gotten kind of
shady too like they were being just as bad as the
empire in some ways part of the reason for that
is laying the track work to show you how someone
like thrawn can come in it almost overthrow
the new Republic because it still existed by
the time of the sequel Trilogy much much later in
the timeline so we know at some point they will
survive Grand Admiral thrawn if you haven't read
the original thrawn trilogy I would definitely
recommend doing that even though they're not
doing that exact story it's Loosely based on
that like the thrawn movie that they announce will
be Loosely based on heir to the Empire then dark
force Rising then the last command basically my
early Theory right now is that that new thrawn
movie will be like their new main movie and that
will turn into a Trilogy and it will loosely all
the events of the original thrawn trilogy with all
the Mandalorian and spin-off series filling the
gaps in between those movies one of the terms we
use is you know the war between the New Republic
and the remnant Empire so we're gonna see you
know you need a conflict and I'm uh you know
just kind of looking at a lot of the things that
were written over the years in various expanded
universe projects trying not just to look at what
John and I did but we're looking at what was done
kind of historically in the time period as a
guide I think for you know generations of Star
Wars fans before the era of uh you know episode
789 that was what what we saw as we first Return
of the Jedi era when you're talking about story
and characters I think in the expanded universe
so there's a treasure of things to to draw from
not just within our own series but uh in the in
the bigger Galaxy they do have the other movies
that they announced in different parts of the
timeline like the dawn of the Jedi movie the
very beginning of what eventually became the
Jedi Order then the new movie that's meant to be
a sequel to the sequel Trilogy like it's 15 years
after the rise of Skywalker but I think those two
movies will wind up being a little bit later I
guarantee you we probably will not hear a whole
lot about those new movies for a little while
like they'll be mostly focused on what's happening
with Ahsoka and this part of the timeline with the
Disney plus series but because the Mandalorian
series is getting up there in Seasons that will
continue for a little while longer but eventually
the Ahsoka series will become like the main new
series all the actors were talking about how
they basically plan on doing multiple seasons
of Ahsoka we've gotten some cameos with Ahsoka in
previous seasons of the Mandalorian we've gotten
some teasers for what life has been like for
Ahsoka these last couple of years since Return
of the Jedi but during her series we'll see what
life is really like for her day to day living the
life of someone who follows her own path through
the force which grogu has kind of started to do
now but he's a little child basically she's
been doing this for a long time now following
this path through the force even though they
use the title Jedi during the trailers she is
not a Jedi like she doesn't call herself a Jedi
anymore they even said that in previous series
I destroyed him if I will avenge his death
revenge is not the Jedi way I am no Jedi part of
the reason why I think they use the Jedi term in
the trailers is just for casual fans that aren't
familiar with the Clone Wars or Star Wars Rebels
Dave vellone did say that that was a challenge
because there's a large portion of the fan base
that never watched the animated series and only
watch the live action stuff so they kind of had
to do a speed run reintroduction to a character
like this is who Ahsoka is this is how she fits
into the timeline this is how she's connected
to the other main characters people view as main
characters like Anakin Skywalker Darth Vader Luke
Skywalker Obi-Wan Kenobi everybody else but the
other interesting thing is that Dave filoni said
that she's meant to be a bridge between what came
before like the old ways of the Jedi the old ways
of the force users and the potential new ways
that we might see develop in the future which
I think gets into the idea of what grogu will
eventually become like he left the Jedi Order
he left Luke Skywalker so he's following his
own path what is he going to become someday
this also gets into what's happening with
the antagonist during the series I wouldn't
call them villains but they are kind of like
the other side of this equation with grandad
thrawn balin's skull played by Ray Stevenson may
he rest in peace he passed away since I post my
last trailer video so it is really sad it was
really sudden they haven't really announced what
happened they confirmed my earlier theory that he
was a former Jedi that survived Order 66 and has
been living as a mercenary ever since the events
of Revenge of the Sith Dave filoni also confirmed
what's going on with the orange lightsabers he
said that they're specifically not meant to be
read like they're not meant to be pure says
they're meant to be something else and it's
meant to sort of play into the idea that Ahsoka
is also not a Jedi technically either like she's
a former Jedi who's still a force user following
her own path through the force in Balance school
this other antagonistic character who's kind of
like a dark Jedi that's about as close as you
could call it a dark Jedi but not a Sith following
his own path but he just bent a little bit darker
than say someone like Ahsoka or another gray Jedi
or someone like that would be the bendu would be
another good example that somebody who practices
both dark side and Light Side they also explain
what's happening with Sabine Wren and Hera when
things pick up so the actors who plays the bean
Natasha Lou bordizo said that the only Mission she
has in this series is to find Ezra Bridger like
that's her main reason for going with thehsoka
when she shows up on lothal like look things have
changed we have a big mission you need to come but
Hera in Ahsoka are both concerned mostly with this
threat that's coming to the Galaxy which is Grand
Admiral thrawn they got a teaser for that in the
end of the Mandalorian season 3 with the shadow
Council they also want to find Ezra Bridger as
well because he was lost at the end of Star Wars
Rebels with Ron but now that thrawn's back that
means that Ezra is probably back too but for those
two Ezra is more like a side quest whereas it's
like the main quest for Sabine Wren during the
trailer there's a nice new scene of Sabine using
Ezra's lightsaber fighting shinhati this other
dark Jedi who's The Apprentice of balen's skull
it looks like the fight scene is still happening
on lothal before they leave the reason why she
has Ezra's lightsaber is because when they went
to fight Admiral thrawn in the Star Wars Rebels
finale he left it with chopper before they were
taken by the space Wells the purgles which we
saw in the Mandalorian another big teaser for
them coming back and it looks like Chopper has
stayed with her all these years after that one of
the last things that Ezra talked to her about was
protecting lothal so she's trying to take that
mission like she stayed on lothal and tried to
keep the peace there are a couple other brand
new scenes of Ahsoka running away from that
same Jedi Temple runes in the previous trailers as
it collapses or it blows up it looks like she has
some kind of fight or something happens when she's
inside there there's another totally different
scene of her wasting one of thrawn's HK droids as
she prepares to fight that Sith Inquisitor which
is from those previous scenes of their fight just
like a longer version of that fight then they had
the same scene that the Jedi Droid played by David
Tennant from the Clone Wars it's meant to be the
exact same character like David Tennant came
back to do the character again he was the Jedi
Professor Droid on the ship that went to illum
as part of the Gathering process it was a big
ceremony that the Jedi had over many thousands of
years to craft their lightsabers there's another
scene of him here on what seems like ahsoka's ship
so it seems like the Jedi Droid has stayed with
Ahsoka but that's not totally clear they also
released a couple other previews of brand new
scenes this one isn't clear where it's happening
this could be where they're meeting with the new
Republic talking about the threat of grand Admiral
thrawn because it looks like it's happening in a
fairly official setting this scene is actually
taken directly from the end of rebels like it's
one of those live-action versions of the Star
Wars Rebels ending with her coming to get Sabine
and them standing in front of that same mural
they also remind you she's got her Mandalorian
armor there from the Star Wars Rebels series
it was weird that she did not show up during
the Mandalorian season 3 finale there were rumors
about that happening but even tamura Morrison said
that Boba Fett was supposed to have a cameo at
the end of the Mandalorian season 3 and it sounds
like based on what the other Mandalorian actors
said they wound up cutting a lot of stuff just
for budgetary reasons too then they have another
new scene of that Sith Inquisitor in the armor
on the same planet where you see Ahsoka talking
about Grand Admiral thrawn returning and being
the heir to the Empire like named after the book
who is the Sith Inquisitor because they playing up
like this big mystery like why are they wearing a
mask if they didn't want it to be this huge reveal
they're using a traditional Sith Inquisitor
lightsaber so that's why we're calling it
another Sith Inquisitor but a lot of people were
wondering if it's just gonna wind up being Ezra
Bridger underneath the mask and something weird
has happened during his time with thrawn in the
outer rim like has he been mind controlled what's
happened to him because why would they put the
Sith Inquisitor under a mask if they didn't want
the mask to come off in for it to be this big WTF
reveal like I couldn't believe the person we've
been looking for this whole time has been right
in front of us so we didn't realize it because
part of the trailers that we've seen before have
been this big mystery about what happened to
Ezra Bridger like what if he's in front of us
this whole time and during the previous trailers
they cut immediately from a scene of Sabine Wren
looking at Ezra bridger's picture with Ahsoka
saying there aren't many of us Jedi left to a
shot of her fighting The Inquisitor who seems like
he's way taller than Ahsoka the lightsaber hilt is
also totally different from the one that shinhati
is using here so I think the way they edited the
trailer they want you to make the connection to
Ezra Bridger and this Sith Inquisitor now it could
totally be a completely different character but
remember this scene the fight with The Inquisitor
is happening when she's wasting this thrawn HK
Droid so I think The Inquisitor is connected
to thrawn in some way but so is Ezra Bridger it
could be a totally unique like one-off character
like just like a very brief thing that they brush
past really quickly and if you're thinking about
parallels with the original trilogy like
the other Star Wars movies remember when
Luke Skywalker fought Darth Vader on Cloud City
and Empire Strikes Back using Anakin Skywalker's
former lightsaber think about it this way if
Sabine Wren has Ezra's former lightsaber what
if she winds up fighting that Sith Inquisitor
with their lightsaber and that person winds
up being Ezra Bridge or it'd be a nice parallel
for that Empire Strikes Back scene it's not true
now because that raises so many questions It could
wind up being a totally different character let
me know in the comments who you think the Sith
Inquisitor is if they're playing it up like this
big WTF mystery like what if the mask comes off
and everybody freaks out and it's somebody that
we know but because episodes are coming August
23rd we'll get more trailers while the secret
Invasion episodes the Marvel stuff is happening
of course I'll be doing videos for that stuff too
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss any of that they also just released a
new secret Invasion trailer video so I'll do
a video for that as soon as possible there's
a bunch of big stuff happening in the next week
especially The Flash movie a bunch of other big
movies going on right now too click here for my
brand new Mandalorian season 4 video and all about
Cal kestus and live action and click here for my
Star Wars acolyte trailer video in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!